because it out all for the Camaro take
my shoes so I'll right here okay and
then the Andrew gets on top you have to
cover my crotch I'm in a bareback so
fabric judgin be spider-man and pepper
would have to really keep spider-man
later all right
hey I'll look at the camera to close the
a pose what is my writing really we did
it everyone come on I'm getting hard we
did it hey everybody
the things we do for art
what's going on reject nation I'm Greg
Alba I'm John Humphrey
I'm Andrew Gordon from the movie source
channel saying of last name now hell
yeah
so guys we spent about an hour making
our notes so we can try to be as
efficient as possible here we saw it
last night with Andrew enter saw it
again today actually dedication in
dedication indeed and he wrote down like
a lot of Easter eggs and so as we're
making our notes we want to write down
only the scenes you felt like touching
on as well as throwing in the Easter
eggs when those scenes come up so it's
like we're going to do this spoiler
review while inserting the Easter egg
knowledge and a pretty much 99% of it
came from Andrews observations not from
John and I'm okay so that's why Andrews
in the Federative day because he
probably no doubt has the most knowledge
on the film more than I do right now
thanks for the Craig Greg you helped out
a little too oh very little hyperedge to
just organize some notes so we got notes
here we're going to be looking through
them let's get to it
all right so online they released they
said the first four minutes of
spider-man homecoming which is actually
not the first four minutes the first
four minutes of the film first like five
ten is actually a prologue of the film
but I thought was really interesting
it's you see Michael Keaton's character
Adrian Toomes
and the events after it takes place like
right after the events of the first
Avengers when the incident of energy or
the Battle of New York occurred and he's
trying to pick up all the scraps from
all the alien wreck wreckage and whatnot
but then you know corporations damn
corporate America said the Tony Stark
says no they gotta go sniffing revolu
the little guy and I thought this scene
was really good because it says some
Asian James is just a normal guy who
cares about his employees cares about
his family you could see that he's a
good person he has good intentions and
he overall has a pretty good heart who
just gets dict over like a lot of people
in America and now straw that broke the
camel's that and all that broke the
camel's back and a big theme and I
noticed a lot of superhero movies has
become the consequences of destruction
the consequence is that when heroes come
out to to save the world and
here's what's happening there's is how
this villain develops and they cut they
cut to like eight years later where now
he's been developing all this technology
he pretty much has the vulture suit
already assembled and he has some big
plans and big plans now as you watch you
get this out of the way get your rip out
of the way about the whole eight years
thing all right so really quick this
movie is like you just said in the
prologue it was set in the Battle of New
York which takes place in 2012 the same
year the film came out now they said
this is eight years later which means
eight plus twelve last time I checked
was twenty right so 2020 so 2020 is when
they're saying this is well they also
did an exact science
yeah right well they also made mention
that this is a couple months after Civil
War and Civil War took place in 2016 so
how could Peter Parker how could it be
four years later in Peter Parker's 15 in
2020 that makes no sense my guess is the
guy who whoever was doing the editing or
whoever does that the the font of eight
years like you just made a complete
mistake it should have been four or five
years later well there were six
screenplay writers on this I wanted them
to know the maker mr. Vegas the K the
baby is weird and they excellent bison
but he's not that hard to change his
title well one of them made a mistake
what do you think of that a prologue st.
John well I saw the prologue he was
great I mean I really liked everything
they did with the with the vulture and I
thought that was a great foundation to
lay in as a very relatable
understandable situation you felt for
the guy and really pays off a lot of the
things that come back later so the way
the movie started with him I thought was
terrific and I was it was cool to start
the movie out in a place that was
different than I was expecting I've
started out with the vulture instead of
Peter Parker and then let that you know
what does the vlog piece that comes
later be that much more surprised I
think the reason why we're touching so
much on the prologue is because it sets
up a supporting character more than a
villain he feels like the main
supporting character as opposed to just
being the villain territory but it's
good already from the prologue I know
you had some Easter eggs you notice were
even possible Easter eggs yeah whatever
and just really quick before I go in
these series I just want to add I love
what you guys are saying they did make
this a sympathetic character and I know
that's something that they've done in a
lot of spider-man films where you know
the villain is not totally evil and
doesn't want to rule the world and kill
people he's just doing he's a victim of
circumstance so I did like that they did
that and I really felt the Michael
Keaton's performance was incredible and
I don't Marvel sometimes as this
reputation of not having the greatest
villains ever but I really enjoyed him
as the vulture he was very menacing and
threatening with spider-man so I really
felt this force and like I said I'm not
agreeing with what he was doing but I
understood why he did what we did and
get his motivation and he's a villain
that clearly thinks he's doing what he's
got to do is doing the right thing for
his yeah you know and that first eight
minutes really sets it up well
definitely definitely I just the Easter
eggs that I references I kind of noticed
we see the Leviathan there from the
battle New York that was the same
Leviathan that Hulk and Thor were on
when they took it down into New York
Central Station and then Hulk punches
for right out of the way so that's that
same Leviathan that was a really cool
moment we also got to see what the one
of the characters we got to see was a
Phineas Mason that's the Tinker and we
get to see him obviously playing
extended not an extender role but kind
of a you know his the guy who built the
gadgets which is a supporting - yeah
which is what he did in the comics he's
got like a super genius level of in
terms of his brain where he can just
build something out of nothing and just
ride in here yeah he can just turn into
a really cool stuff which is what he was
in this film I also liked his humor in
the film - I thought it was very funny
like when he was answering his text
messages and saying yeah I'm a charming
character of nature and I've got
something like that but those cool those
are also a nation those are all very
nice touches and and when the film has
that the vlog that Peter Parker's
creating they released that whole thing
online which I did enjoy watching I did
a reaction to it but it does work even
better in the context of the prologue
plus the Marvel logo and then having
that there because if smash cuts to a
film by Peter Parker and you're just not
expecting that even as someone who saw
the footage I wasn't expecting that to
be the very next image yeah my brain
skipped a beat for a second when I
and I was those I didn't see that
footage so that was so much fun to watch
the navigator and to see going from you
on the prologue to that it almost jarred
me when we jump back into real movie
mode you know yeah because it was an
interesting way to structure the film
you know set up a set the villain and
then you're continuing your
reintroduction of Peter Parker from
Civil War and picking up the event and
around his perspective his perspective
which is really different yeah exactly
it's like it's the most high-stakes
moment in civil war but it's like he'd
have a great time than like a field trip
and yeah it's a great transition from a
directional point of view to put you in
the point of view of Peter Parker
because when you last saw Peter Parker
it wasn't from his point of view at all
he's a fun surprise in that film and
here it's like no we're going to put you
in the point of you in the whole film is
pretty much from his perspective also to
what I like that they touched upon just
in those moments I thought Jon Favreau
was so funny as a happy Hogan and some
of those clothes as well it's more
depressed every time you return um Jon
Favreau's character yeah um but also to
like you said seeing from Peters
perspective I just like seeing that kid
in him like how excited he was when he
got to Berlin and then not realizing how
much bigger the room really was because
he's not used to having a room like that
like I really loved it so and then how
excited he was when he gets that new
soon that suit is so freaking awesome
too by the way but again like just and
then you get to see some of the cool
stuff that we got to see in the airport
scene from Captain America Civil War
one little other continuity riff that I
had wasn't that big one but when a man
turns into giant man if you remember
correctly in Captain America Civil War
right when that happened spider-man says
holy [ __ ] and this he says oh this guy
got really big I gotta go and then we
don't really hear one [ __ ] so I don't
know that I guess that was kind of a
continuity or because surely journaler
stood with his cameras it doesn't have a
rapport it doesn't have repair icon that
I don't
rather if the ruses approved of that
peter parker's but probably not probably
but i get Tom home still not all himself
nobody yeah
and the you pointed out that continuity
thing that you really appreciate about
that they show that scene pretty much
they're like a lot of the trailers and I
think even released the clip online when
Robert Downey jr. is sitting in the
limousine with Tom Hall and in the
backseat and you point out the black eye
really and that's a cool attention to
detail he pointed out show that it is
picking up a little bit after Civil War
so in a lot of people might not even
care about it really notice but that's
cool you notice that because I love
little attention to detail like that
matters so have the fans especially like
yourself means they're paying attention
to their own continuity not eight years
later when it might be sometimes really
2017 but yeah and of course you know we
get the Michael Giacchino score that's a
riff on the 60s theme song which is
badass I was actually I was doing cardio
today at the gym and I was playing that
I mean I really I really loved his
rendition of that song
I think it's badass I mean a lot of
people are saying like I hear a lot of
people walk across the map really
talking about like Danny Elfman's scores
so being the best I'm not here to
compare but there is a certain love and
enthusiasm that just naturally comes as
this feeling like a really big fan film
of spider-man as well I agree and also
to just really quick note I believe
Michael Giacchino composed Doctor
Strange in last year denotes work in a
ton way Leandro unwanted ones yeah a lot
of these big temple stuff yeah The Mummy
did you do the moaning oh I'm
transformers think wizard Steve
Jablonsky Paper Towns maybe that in the
movie it comes a night that's it follows
you didn't score that decision for you
man up video is incredible than the
Incredibles you're a shirred the Christ
let's move on no no all right then yeah
so and then as the Phil keeps going
because you know we don't want to cover
every single scene here but there's a
little Easter eggs that you were
noticing as we're catch it because one
thing the song does really need were and
it cuts to two months later has all
these nice little details and touches
of the plot of Peter Parker just really
wanting to go on another mission and
want to become an official Avenger I
love the little touch of just him I
think he's writing the train and she's
like texting happy and you see is doing
that teenager desperate thing where he
sees all these messages he's either
happy yeah who doesn't be here otherwise
Parker in this china media we can all
relate to that I've done that with many
women and John plenty of times and as
their other goes there's a lot of
catching up with Peters lack of just
being a high school boy they have that
moment that they show in the trailer
where he is watching himself on YouTube
and you notice something yeah I also
there's an easter egg there's a couple
Easter eggs in that scene you notice
that a Bruce Banner his picture is on
the wall
obviously Bruce Banner is of course the
Hulk and he's an expert in gamma
radiation so I got imagined in a school
full of a gifted school of science like
that Bruce Banner is an inspiration to
the other that kind of generation yes
are good and end up setting up your next
possible Easter Egg Angela thank you for
letting me do that I think there's a set
of trig but yeah these the next one that
I kind of noticed more today was the
teacher mentions when Peter gets the
question right she says see flash being
being fast isn't everything
I kind of feel like that was a little
bit of a easter egg 200 it's well flash
sorry
well flash according to your Notes oh my
dad sure she's this guy see he's got
sighs and I got I got everything all
right I'm gonna go pull up the script
it's usually so I guess it's welcome at
there's a fascist and everything but
like also I've note I remember too and
some of the other spider-man films but
took noir ones they mentioned DC
characters where Tommy where said Shazam
and two films of Iron Man ones the rain
also rosemary Harris's Aunt May when
they were in the hospital she says to
spider-man you're not Superman so how do
you make some DC references here yeah
you know I happen they're referencing
the fact of DC just you know it doesn't
take their time yeah
little jab there yeah you know it now
that you have it that actually might be
to be a Kevin Feige he's taking his stem
and figured out the jack is that flash
so we'll going to be first if some of my
favorite moments of this film that we
mentioned are nonce where there are all
the things that seem semi spoof but are
also answering questions the things that
you've wondered how to spider-man deal
with situations like this so they have
the scene where he takes them a long
time to get this suit on when he's like
getting change in the alleyway where
does he put his backpack he webs does it
like little cool touch where he was is
backpack really quick to the wall I'm
always booth a program and it takes a
long time again I'm dressed and get his
clothes on and you pointed out to me
something that Tom said went back to the
future John actually I point out
something in reference to the Easter Egg
that Andrew brought up so this really
just because you know you can at least
draw it with a little parallel between
you know the way his suit kind of
vacuum-sealed kind of like the sides of
just on Marty's jacket and Tom all I
didn't say that he wanted to be this
generations Marty McFly no yeah maybe a
little self-awareness there and after
you something I'm like that is probably
the word I would have used to the words
already used to describe Town Hall he is
the Marty McFly picked up of a cinematic
universe so we got a DHS on edge
hi cracking boys hold on Doc da and what
do they what do they call the school
needs John you would know the right word
for that oh I don't call the school news
you have school news at your school well
we had yeah during homeroom we would
have the video production class would
yeah the video production class yeah I
love the touch of that with the two
anchors talking to each other and they
felt like real awkward high school kids
doing that's why I had the kinds of
graphics and glass screen effects that
you would see it that was it but Andrew
another research he noticed there and I
heard some people in the crowd oh ho ho
when when her name the female anchor was
pointed out to say it and right well
this is of course Betty Brant who last
time we saw her in a spider-man film was
played of course by Elizabeth Banks say
can you read a repulses and Power
Rangers a director of pitch perfect -
hey
supporting role in sea bisque aka
showerhead 40 year old virgin hmm
sorry Cyril we can roll we're here to do
that so yeah thanks Brent like I said
last time we saw her was Corsa and the
Tobey Maguire series played by Elizabeth
Banks also if you know anything about
this character I believe she was the
first girl friend of Peter Parker in the
comics also she is the secretary of j
jonah Jameson and she also marries Ned
Leeds in the comics who's the third hop
Goblin I don't know this is nedley's I
know that as a specular yes--she
chelation because they didn't really
mention his last name we know his name
is Ned obviously he's playing a little
bit of a version of gangee egg I think
it's King Keeley from a Miles Morales
his best friend and the ultimate
spider-man Universal he's got a lot of
touches upon from Yankee Lee but I mean
it could be Ned lead so that something
maybe to speculate on absolutely
absolutely and you had a note that you
wanted to point out about and not be in
a public school yeah good point I I
really I came up with that point yeah go
it was good dragon what happened I got
him up with the idea to remind you
enough that's sure John to do that we're
doing our part you go anyways yeah I did
notice that and the other versions we've
gotten of the Spider Man you notice that
he's in a public school and in this
version it's more of a private school
sending us it's a and if they're on the
Tony Stark scholarship so I thought that
was really cool not only having he had
an alibi of you know the Tony Stark
being of the intern that's what you know
is a good alibi for him for lying to
people about where his whereabouts are
so I like that in bull contentiousness
and also to actually add and I think
about it adds weight to the importance
of him being in school because it's a
private school because I think naturally
our minds will take a private school
much more serious determine the academic
stuff it has opposed to being in public
school yeah no I agree because like you
just said if he gets kicked out of a
public school I mean that definitely
would suck but you can just go to
another public this is a very rare
opportunity for someone in his you know
and his money arrangements for the
amount of money as an make so I think
you know it's definitely a great
opportunity that Tony's giving him and
Tony he doesn't want to see him blow it
so I like that that was a big contention
of point of the film about Tony is such
a mentor in this home form absolutely
hey John remember that deli scene
yeah what did you think of that scene I
mean I I liked that scene a lot and that
scene exemplifies something I
appreciated about this movie a whole lot
which is you know you get a sense for
the community castle and ER you it's
kind of Peter doing in everyday sort of
thing you know having a little rapport
with just somebody from the neighborhood
is not a huge part of his life but is
someone he's going to end up saving
later and it makes sense I think it adds
to the whole theme of him being the
friendly neighborhood spider-man because
it and more than just him being another
hero addition to New York City part of
the MCU it shows that even as Peter
Parker this is his neighborhood I get
the sandwiches chance with the guy at
the counter he pets the cat makes him
more personal for him being a hero there
and also when he's talking to mr. Delmar
the guy who's in charge of the name you
got to get that name right man oh yeah
when he's talking to mr. Delmar I love
the interaction where he's like he
thinks he's sneaking up talking about
his and in Italian and then I'm in Peter
Parker comes back with a good quip like
how's your daughter yeah I'm like I just
I love that interaction because it not
only shows that Peter Parker obviously
is very intelligent he knows different
languages but he's willing he's like
peas like spider-man is willing to come
back with a funny quip that you know I
love that it just it felt like it and by
the the character of Peter Parker
environments little touches like that
little moments like that yeah and before
the bank robbery seemed possible Easter
Egg ain't that right Andrew yeah no
there is a possible one this is just
speculation I don't know if we're going
to call it an Easter Egg but the happy
Hogan does mention to Peter over the
phone that they're going to upstate New
York for the New Avengers facility and
that the Tony has sold a vendor's tower
now there's not obviously a lot of
people in New York who can paper you
know something like Avengers Tower
that'd be quite an expensive commodity
so I was thinking possibly could be
Norman Osborn you know it was obviously
the Green Goblin and in charge of oz
group that'd be a cool way to introduce
them in now that he's kind of bought the
vendors over I'm going to speculate on
that's true as good as a cool scene I
liked it I think this scene played out a
lot because in the way the the trailer
had to go down where you see the bank
robbery scene it kind of just looks like
a bank robbery scene and spider-man
saves a day and then when you watch the
movie you're like oh there's actually
one of the most important scenes of the
whole plot a lot of stuff because that
scene becomes
a pretty big intro for the the firepower
that the vultures yeah supplying the the
criminals in the area with and the face
of destruction felt apparent right when
the deli got destroyed yeah I was even
concerned for mr. Delman I said I've
confirmed concern for the cat answer for
the cat to this guy can't stand watching
animals dot don't do it filmmaker don't
and then when we're an act to now that's
like Act one word oh I'm sorry I got to
point out something in the bank robbery
scene he does mentioned a Hulk or fake
Hulk and fake forward and says hey ho
forward nice to meet you guys this is a
reference to Captain America Civil War
where Hulk and Thor were missing in that
film environment did not get to meet
them so I thought that was a kind of
little probe throwback to that which was
funny that's why you're the movie source
channel and now that we're in action now
we are you has a reference to Uncle Ben
that you notice that I actually kind of
split over my head yeah when he when Ned
has finally discovered Peter Parker
spider-man kind of said I'm gonna level
with you I don't think I can keep this a
secret but this is the first thing I've
ever happened to me yeah and then
they're going through that whole
interaction you'd say you can't tell
them it with everything that it may has
been through that's a reference to Uncle
Ben they didn't really make any
references to Uncle Ben a by his name
like Uncle Ben but they make little self
touches and also in Captain America
Civil War so when bad things happen and
then things you could something like I'm
putting the line but when he was talking
to Tony Stark he was recruiting him that
was of course a reference back to Uncle
Ben too so they make what I like how
they make little subtle references to
Uncle Ben without actually saying Uncle
Ben because we've seen that whole plot
and storyline in the Amazing Spider
Minter's and the Raimi series so nice
little subtle touches absolutely John I
did a reaction to the scene when net
discovers that Peter Parker is
spider-man so we have a common area
there already but I like how it all
proceeded after that how it affects a
lot of the tone in the chemistry and the
vibe of these two characters they have
this really great montage of ned
pestering peter look with questions
while they're at school Peters is trying
to concentrate on doing a zone ring and
getting and doing assignments while
getting through the day but Ned just all
he cares about is knowing more about
what it's like to be spider-man because
you can see like Ned kinda has is
envious but enthusiastic vibe about it
and there was some Easter eggs in there
too
Andrew that is my cue yes so was some of
the ones I noticed he says him can you
can you bring in our army of ants or
arranged an army of ants something like
I'm butchering the line a little bit but
that's that are spiders sorry it really
should have been ants because that's who
he's referencing ant-man so I thought
that was a little bit of an immune
reference he also says do you spit venom
kind of doubt that a little bit of a
venom reference office and we know Tom
Hardy has been cast as venom and
obviously Amy Pascoe kind of butchered
explaining if you know whether that was
connected but Kevin Feige and Tom Bowen
couldn't clear the air and so they're
not connected which doesn't make me
happy per se but uh nothing you are ever
going to know the truth until is I think
we should stop talking about homecoming
and spend the next 25 minutes talking
about venom for grace bring it back just
hitting who dated that you know what I
got a kick out of that one scene when
when I when Ned first discovers him is
the fact that Peters is underwear for
most of that scene an anime comes in and
doesn't bat an eye at at just the
oddness of there wasn't like a it's like
a gauge you're thinking yeah is almost
cool as they just did yeah just make so
well I put a crappy sprocket some
clothes on yeah yeah I guess you need
her so I'm gonna just do that thought to
like did he just drop his spider-man
soon on the ground or did he throw it
kind of happened so fast I didn't really
notice how you got out of notice yeah
they also wanted the history I think it
was one of the history teachers was
talking about the sokovia accords and we
all know that the sokovia accords it
drove it was the backbone of would hold
the Avengers apart in Captain America
Civil War so that was a nice little
reference and just really quickly adding
on to what you said about Ned you know
the discovery of him flying off your
part what I love about that is it's nice
that Peter can finally confine and talk
to someone about you know his powers and
stuff because you can imagine I think
Ned laid it out best what's it like
being so famous and no one even knows
about it like it's nice that he has
someone you can talk to about it and you
know the guy in the chair like you know
I love that it's nice to have a
spider-man that doesn't have to be all
alone and they've got great chemistry
together their interactions it's so much
fun and they're so great together
they're interesting they're funny their
lines of dialogue or I was laughing out
loud I might a few like real teenagers
yeah and I love that moment to when he
opened the locker
want to build the Death Star the girl
like it'll gross he's like yeah I'm like
yeah this is like us when we were
growing up at John
Captain America PSAs want to talk about
oh man well throughout this movie this
through line of these just little little
sugary just jokes man this is for every
situation Captain America has apparently
recorded a PSAs they're like in gym
class at one point they're in detention
at one point and Captain America's is
always professing you know the the the
you know the truth justice and the
American Way to the kids that's Superman
but you know what I mean I'm but it's
hilarious so I remember my my hinge
about it looks like one of the crossover
moments really it's really funny that
you had that and it seems fitting for
what Captain America at least would have
done before I was wondering when they
shot those PSAs though you mean the
terms of the story in the movie or in
the real allotted timeline oh yeah I
know that I can tell you that soup that
he's wearing is clearly the soup from
the first Avengers film with Joss Whedon
it's actually my least favorite Captain
America I have color that television in
2012 I believe they do know Oh what wait
a minute not the First Avenger the first
Avengers captain no no no the first
Avengers sorry my bad that's funny no
not Captain America the First Avenger
Joss Whedon's the Avengers that's
because it's not that the suit that
you're referring to from the first
offenders that goes into the museum
after in Winter Soldier so I'm not
talking about that I think when they
woke him up is when they did that yeah I
know that but I wait around a nap that
that is their kids need your help man
right around the time right after the
Battle of New York for sure because up
to the point where you got four unfrozen
and then you battle obviously we saw the
battle New York so it's got to be right
after that again that's the suti war
right before Winter Soldier so it's for
sure right around that timeline 2012
he's got to do something when he's not
fighting crime cuz you know that is not
like he's just fighting all the time
it's true and I like Hannibal Buress at
the gym co-chair is pretty sure this
guy's a war criminal but whatever it's
not-it's sarin and you also said kept it
in your gym teacher that's me
are you standing alongside the T because
just like little little touches like
that like even the jokes got jokes yeah
and when they're at the gym and Tom
Holmes do
crunches and you're like me yeah that
makes sense and now we're doing the
crunches I love the moment when they're
overhearing because it seemed like was
oh I'm going to hear Liz Alan talk
talking they're all talking about like
you think spider-man suit and she had a
little crush on spider-man that whole
scene and what it leads into was perfect
to me because it was like this is that
taking advantage of him being in high
school this specific moment right here
not just I'm trying to balance homework
and all this stuff with it it's the
social situation and the pressure
because I like the idea of him feeling
pressure to reveal himself so he can get
the girl because I'm like damn you know
I when I was younger and sometimes now I
imagine like man let super-powered and I
want to reveal that's the girl
impression uh how cool would that be
yeah there was like coming-of-age trial
yeah you know especially that's some of
the richest stuff in the high school
unity that is the social quality and
some of the intense like consequence
moments for me when I would be like Oh
Carter like high school moments when Ned
says oh you know if I realize I retire I
think both you and I realize you did
that because you guys were doing that
you didn't see me doing that - yeah
here's the way you'll see no evil speak
good we don't do that coming when he
when he does that but I like how that
scene ended I mean could be nerves
that's when you you see a little bitty
receive flash bullying um I was at
actor's name is held on rebel lower yeah
who's great on movie fights great and
grand Budapest hotel
pootis grand Budapest if it never dealt
is really good also to deciding like I
liked some of the conversating real teen
conversations like Betty Brant when
she's speaking to them she's like I I
would ask for uh I would marry marry
Iron Man and I would kill Hulk lay and I
got the rap word in there and it will
also Aunt May at the end or aunt BAE as
I like the color at the end
I like her split up is to almost efforts
in this movie yeah but that moment I'm
like that makes sense why Ned would do
that and so and it wasn't a moment where
you're like now you're an idiot now I
hate this character I didn't feel that
way especially because of the
conversation that proof the common
wingman informs yeah because the
conversations not proceeded after with
him stain like how Peter should take
advantage of this you know and cuz I
understood that and there was a part of
it like Danny Peterson think of it like
sitting the audience knowing he's not
going to but there's a part of me that
kind of does you want Peter do you can
understand the pressure of him being
tempted to do that and that's within the
spider-man
you know mythos over time there's that
idea that like Peter knows Thunderman
yeah and the party scene to like you
those high school touches were great
because Peter doesn't want to go to the
high school party he has other things on
his mind but it registers to like Aunt
May that oh it's just social anxiety he
doesn't want to go out there buddy and
that was understand what I remember
being young and going to parties and
even now when I go to parties I'm not
that familiar with I still kind of get
this uncomfortable dark social anxiety
feeling I feel like net a lot of parties
standing there with my hat and when they
going to go in there and even his little
and his awkward interaction with Liz I
find great defeat everyone's quoting
Flash Thompson when I say penis you say
Parker Peters Parker what you guys think
we didn't talk about her knots what
would you guys think what's your overall
opinion of Flash in this movie I thought
I mean I thought he did a good job I
like Tony over Laurie I thought like I
thought everything about that character
was good it just there wasn't a ton of
like really standout moments oh yeah you
know he's just the high school bully
I like him to do a little bit more what
I mean I appreciate one thing I
appreciate about what they did
difference with him I know we're not
going like scene order now but was I
pretty sure about the difference with
him is that they made him a nerd he
wasn't just some jock bully or he's a
totally different look than everything
we've seen before I feel like they
learned from 21 Jump Street without
calling direct attention to that because
21 Jump Street raises a good point is
like cool kids are different yeah
and I can do intellectual [ __ ] until
become the trolls on the Internet art
nerds yeah yeah that not only did they
make him a nerd but in this he's
actually jealous of Peter Parker because
Peters got his spot on the Decathlon
taters the smartest one yeah and also
like in the rainy ones like even though
flash is not at all big role in that
series with Joe Manganiello
we did we know Peter is jealous and
emkin sees Mary Jane's boyfriend and
he's got the card he's got a girl so I
like how they changes up in this making
him more jealous of Peter you know like
any chance he gets to be a douche in
them he's just going to do it just yeah
he's so jealous of them and it builds up
his douchery to the point where when we
see what happens at the end with the
allottee it's like hey that was a good
little revenge Hamlin right there like
you deserved that like so I thought the
character like he pulled up playing a
douche really well and also I just I
liked the different like the variation
like we said that they went for this
version where he's a nerd and he's
jealous of theater absolutely absolutely
but it can pick it up from the party
sequence you know where Pete I love the
moment where Peter actually is rocking
this bodysuit and is debated and
debating should I enter the party and I
was thinking maybe he's going to do it I
was actually contemplating like will be
actually do that and you point out our
non-spoiler John how it's classic
spider-man howl pretty much every action
scene that I'm having to leave something
which messes with his personal life
because he keeps having to leave
something if dampens his personal life
image and it proceeds into that that
sequence where you first meet Aaron
Davis that we don't really need a touch
on that sequence I just think that's a
really beautiful thing about this movie
overall is because that enhances oh that
always enhances attention but you
brought that up earlier about Aunt May
like kind of identifying with him and I
think that's a it's an interesting touch
that they made it like that's that's a
real kind of person in high school you
know they're always bailing out on stuff
what's going on with you you're really
withdrawn you're really yeah you're
really moody with that what's happening
with you and that could be normal stuff
or you could be spiral running there was
a lot more depth in that relationship
not that rosemary Harris is and tell me
why Ursula because there was a lot of
inspirational speeches throughout the
three
and the editors every may is different
yeah all get younger yeah yeah yeah but
anime is gonna be 27 years old yeah with
that and I mean once I guess one thing I
could point out about that first scene
with Aaron Davis is yes shocker one
Jackson Bryce and who's that actor's
name that would be Logan Marshall greens
of them are throwing multiple things in
fact this is an Easter Egg just for me
but both shockers in this movie are in
that movie devil the elevator movie and
they're both in the elevator together
booking woodbine and Logan I am proud to
say I did not come up with that Easter
Egg that is old job underrated movie
check it out yeah that seems good
because I think that enhances what makes
Michael Keaton's Adrian Toomes so smart
because they're out in the park and
they're showing off weapons and I like
Erin I like the way Donald Glover did
that scene like I'm not trying to send
someone back through time yeah I wonder
if you wrote some of those lines for
Michelle's like Donald Glover line yeah
and he plays a guy like he's like on
your rugs - yeah really like really
melancholy that moment I just wanted
something simple because yeah when when
that occurs later when agent tooms is
like mad about
demmick doing that in public that
enhances more on the vultures character
because because it was kind of like when
I did it happen my analytical mind did
go off a little bit going why are they
just doing this in public they like look
how big this is going everyone's going
to be able to see this so I like that
attention to detail there but nothing
doesn't have an effect yeah even that
like that goes to sell later when Adrian
Toomes like you know what get like two
jacks and Brenda's like you know what
get out I don't need you anymore like we
see that moment and it's good because
we're like yeah yeah it seems like your
judgment is not great yeah well yeah and
also - I just like that it points out
that he's got like a little bit of a
code that you know it's all about family
and doing what's right and if you
jeopardize this this organization or
this
you're gone and you're out so I like
about pragmatism - it is true it's like
you want to call attention to us with
this like our whole operation is
clandestine well yeah problem exactly
but going back to that it leads into
this chase sequence that while it was
happening I was thinking this reminds
you so I was like I feel like this is an
80s tribute to something when Peter
Parker when Spiderman is going through
the neighborhoods which is fantastic and
he's like keep sorting people's
backyards and rooftops and sheds and
stuff and the way it was being shot
right away Andrew said that's Ferris
Bueller seconds later they show up every
other scene it's like making it direct
homage to about Ferris Bueller like it's
letting the audience know down which I
thought was fantastic
yeah and it also just lets you know how
much the tone is inspired by the John
Hughes 80s coming against them so I like
that so nice well yeah they're 10 off so
when he's like trying to go to the heat
goes to sweet because I remember when I
watch the 90s cartoon people would even
talk about in some commercials like what
is spider-man swinging on yeah and then
they have the mummer like what does he
do when there's nothing for him to Webb
on yes it just right yes the Tom Cruise
of that [ __ ] yeah that was fantastic I
might have been Tom Cruise in that
spider-man suit just for that scene just
for that TV we don't know a little cameo
let's run her the biz
yeah so as the film keeps going they
eventually figure out if you put Spidey
puts a tracker on them and figures out
that are going Maryland right yeah yeah
they go into Maryland and the best way
for them to get there because spider-man
can't fly he doesn't have access the
money but he is part of the Capitol a
team that's trying to go to Washington
so they make the trip to go to the
Washington decathlon and I love no
jealous again we're talking about flash
of jealousy gets when Peter tries to
come back to things like you think you
can just come back and you'll be
welcomed right away and then the teacher
goes welcome back mr. president yeah not
immediately was like yeah come on I'm
not familiar with Martin stars work now
before you go to the Easter Egg I'm not
familiar with Martin stars worth other
than Silicon Valley knocked up and I go
for always that's right he's oh yeah
he's the guy with the beard yeah
and growing the beard out yeah I give up
go ahead
Jacob elementary Cola well you know what
it was really nice because he usually
has this very significant oh sorry in
fact one of his co-stars on Freaks and
Geeks is a co-writer on this movie and
has the story credit John free on Fraley
yeah okay
yeah I mean I'm used to him just being
super dry delivery and he's be subtle
here for sure but it was so nice to see
a different side because I've seen him
in Silicon Valley so much of the fun
right on maybe does it he just behaves
this way and you know a lot of his roles
he does have that that very deadpan
thing because even if you go back and
watch those old episodes of freaks and
geeks he has a very odd character I'd
yeah but yeah here is nice to see him
displayed just an affable guy in any
field he's a believable teacher yeah and
I thought it was great but the Easter I
do you have yeah I mean this is kind of
speculative but he's not what's not to
make it is that he was in the Incredible
Hulk and Edward Norton would gives him a
piece of pizza he's credited in that
film as the computer nerd could be maybe
that he graduated after that and then
became a teacher because this is in the
same universe or this is just a very big
coincidence so I thought that was kind
of interesting that he's also Incredible
Hulk and in this is kind of interesting
in that one other thing that was kind of
interesting like I mean you put a vest
like he's just a very like subtle
teacher and all and but there was that
one line ways like when they kind of
survive the Washington Monument will go
into or he's like and I kid can't get
injured on a school trip again or
something like what's going on portal
idiot shooting on sorry yeah yeah again
something like that yeah I'm like that
was like what is pretty time it happened
I was fantastic he doesn't really get
it's dark humor in there but that moment
you got to have that our universe like I
was I really did alike this was nice to
see him almost in a all role instead
benefit of just a gherkin yeah yeah I
mean yeah as the film keeps going with
her at the hotel you know like as much
as we can spend time touching on these
moments we don't want to like spend too
much time to this stuff but I like it
you know they're staying at the hotel
liz is I like how Liz was missing this
character who seemed to like Peter you
know and wants him to get involved and
wants them to get involved and I like
how in
going back to this point that John I've
been talking up how every time he can't
do a personal thing it seems like it
seems understandable because people
always misinterpret it for something
else yeah that oh he's shy or he gets
too consumed with his studies heard you
know something what's up with you yeah
yeah because they don't invited him to
the pool and then makes the kids even
more real when they're doing that and
then he's awkwardly spying on her when
she's in him in her bikini which is
great we've all done that especially
Andrew he does it all the time and you
know it's really the bull ridings were
relatable girls do to guys to not spend
too much time talking about Porky's and
what happens is porky disabled um yeah I
haven't seen what the disabling the suit
john you we were taking notes you drop a
really good point for why you really
like that oh yeah I mean because that
that whole thing informs so much of the
the the second just the middle chunk of
this movie because in trying to hack the
suit and basically take all the training
wheels off and get out of dad's shadow
basically you know a new father figure
shadow that gives him this whole new set
of obstacles that he keeps having to
deal with yeah up until he gets stuck in
the the containment facility so it's I
thought that added so many layers
because you know we've seen this in the
trailer that you know he's at least got
like different things with his
web-shooters than just you know
ziplining around yeah but this is like
the controls and the options become
overwhelming to the point it's actually
messing up his ability to take care of
business yeah stop the heists when he's
trying to do yeah and I thought about
that for a second I was like in when Ned
blades all these other capabilities I
guess I'm just going to open him up and
I was like I wonder if he's going to
know how and then sure enough like this
second something starts to happen it's
completely ruining his ability to do
what he's trying to do that's because
yeah when he eventually makes his way to
Maryland and he's about to stop the the
heist at least would ya the heights were
going down they had this whole that
hilarious sequence of where he just the
webs are not doing what he wants them to
do it
no covering happening - it isn't your
eyes go read that there's a taser mode
and they spread weird I did like that
because the movie when he first disables
it it says he graduates to a next level
sir like Oh Peter just unlocked
something this is good for him but then
it starts to backfire I know the second
he said that looking Greg Duncan
completing the training wheel toe
recalled like oh boy yeah no it's your
voice but that was such a funny scene
when he's trying to figure out how this
series starts of ruining that what is he
you like to destroy something with a
Taser right yeah or yeah he just called
you guys need to go crazy and then also
he falls on his face what just happened
you just fell on your face
yeah has a molecular gamer there too
yeah and I like for this movie like it
in terms of the MCU I like that they
took advantage of bringing this suit
into the world because there are Ironman
things about it he does kind of have a
heads up display with a lot of
holographic imagery and Hoffa and things
but it felt appropriate to spider-man in
this version of the universe yeah it's
just about to say that yet until too
much or too little you know and this in
this incarnation of spider-man I agree
like it makes sense we've already seen
the other version with Tobin aware and
Andrew Garfield where that those that
those suits were not capable of
something like this you didn't have Tony
Stark ax as a mentor in those home so I
like how they're changing around and
making the suit you know with some Iron
Man qualities in it so I thought I was
cool when I loved the heads-up display
in the way you know he's able to use
this is like really caring character
like the female Jarvis inside the Spidey
suit was so fantastic era her from the
comics hunting notes in the comic but I
thought she was so fantastic enter
Easter egg from Andrew alright so
actually a reference to spongebob the
computer wife Karen out oh cool so um so
so the voice of Karen in this is
actually being voiced by Jennifer
Connelly now Jennifer Connelly's you
remind you don't do this I don't know
directed by mark water so Jennifer
Connelly in real life is actually
married to Paul Bettany who is of course
the voice of Jarvis and then now Alden
yeah and also now he is a vision in
the Captain America Civil War Avengers
age of Ultron etc so and also she played
of course Betty Ross and angley's Hulk
so the a nice little cool touch there
and she was really cool because I've not
seen when they get trapped in the
department of damage control how we come
here yeah I'm like them like they had
another like little montage where he's
learning how to use all this stuff and
you know because it's Peter Parker he
can absorb this information really quick
so I'm glad we didn't have to dedicate
too much time to him figuring out this
suit because it makes it much more
enjoyable and it keeps the pacing going
and it made for a really it really made
for a really nice nobody laying down
board and talking with care how long
we've been here there's the opening up
about Liz to and you have a female
companion open up to about it to be a
thing like support it and yeah they have
an actual like little relationship
together yeah it's really heartwarming
and also to when he's messing up in the
suit like I love seeing that too because
it kind of harkens back a little to the
first Iron Man when Tony Stark is first
trying out all the Iron Man stuff and
he's messing up falling all over the
back it kind of like harp ins a little
back to that and I like that cuz it's
showing that the character is not right
away capable of just using this oh you
know because it feels a little bit feels
a little weak leaps of logic like how
did the character rating so how did you
Rebecca well wonder the whole theme in
this movie about Peter being in over his
head the more Peter struggled to take
control and to do the things that people
are encouraging and not to do the more
difficult they get and the less control
he has overall okay so in the department
of damage control a couple of Easter
eggs and a couple and maybe a possible
Easter Egg and just take it away okay so
some of the things I saw in there Peter
when he's going through some of the
stuff we see pulls out one of the Ultron
heads so that's what that was yeah okay
that was pretty cool also on the
Department of damage control from the
comics it was actually co-owned by both
Tony Stark and Wilson Fisk now I know
what Vincent D'Onofrio is of course
Wilson Fisk right now on the Netflix's
daredevil he is mentioned in plenty of
interviews he really wants to be the
kingpin in a spider-man campaign is one
of the main Vil oh hell yeah in the
these answers in the comic book so I've
always wanted to see spider-man go up
against kingpin in the film so I'm not
saying they're gonna do but this could
possibly be a way to introduce the you
know from a plot perspective B so
because of the what I was thinking about
on the car ride back home today that in
the way the movie ends about he wants to
be part of just the neighborhood I'm
like you only got four other heroes in
New York City right now who are
specifically location there and they
have makes sense if spider-man
eventually teamed up with the Daredevils
such a big thing and how Wilson's has
got his money and stuff is from the
Battle of New York the real estate all
it likes remember yeah happen so you can
really just push that in there with the
whole damage control thing so I think
that would work out but you know we'll
see what happen let's face it this
spider-man totally fits with the Netflix
all for sure they almost got you upwards
in hoboes well the scene where Peter
smashes that one guy's head for five
straight minutes later door yeah totally
wow man slam Webb needed a you know a
she's a dude you don't need to do this
right you guys are doing but my best
example would be look what they did with
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine they turned him
from pg-13 will ring and to rated-r
Wolverine and Logan like they can do it
it oh happy
oh I'm saying in terms of making Wilson
Fisk pg-13 Wilson says you can do it and
I love to see Vincent D'Onofrio as
Wilson Fisk in a Spider Man I'm like
that'd be freaking awesome to see him
inspire man just going at it
absolutely spider-man teens up with
Danny Rand it'll be great yeah do you
mean we get that Randy I never ever saw
he was going at the intensity even
though I predicted this because of the
fact that there is a clip about him
going to the decathlon that oh
something's going to happen he's not
going to be able to make the cap along
these guys getting a chap the other and
say like assume that if it's part of
Peters like crime like yeah yeah and I
thought that was really cool because it
has that classic superhero such an
especially Peter Parker touch they're
mad at him for not being able to attend
a decathlon
he's going to get in trouble for this
yet because he didn't attend he was able
to save their lives and he they can
never do it I didn't have a very good
night he's a conflict of all I just
wanted to
I didn't even think that is a great
point is obviously again if he doesn't
go to go on that truck he doesn't find
out that it's really a bomb yeah so now
I think we have it and I was in intense
Tina and I like that because what we put
on our non sorter view is that this is
about him learning how to be spider-man
and what we're so used to from these
prior installments of him zipping around
and jumping off a building with us it is
yeah like climbing the Chrysler Building
in New York all these things and then
and then weighs up on the Washington
Monument he's scared and I remember that
the way that was shot
I got shells in my feet like I know I
felt that feeling in my feet is I'm like
looking really high down here dice and
that was freaking me out and I know
everyone is freaked out there it will
remind you you ain't got your parachute
yeah cuz I was the other thing too is
that was the first thing I thought when
he fell into the water I was a good
thing he dropped him in a lake because I
don't think Peter would survive and that
height and then they clarified and the
Washington Monument II was cool I mean
when he when he goes in there save them
I love the web-shooter thing where she
brings off the wall but my favorite
moment of that when he does say them and
he stays Liz every moment they break the
bank this is what is when are you
looking at her and Karen goes this is
your moment Peter kids also use me
upside down yeah fashion with with
Moratti Byron and water and also with
Gwen Stacy and spider-man yeah they went
on me yes uh cut in that position so it
was kind of like if this is the
spider-man kiss position um so in
sterically and also we got the scene
using the iron with the wings to which
was really good hiding those every time
we got to see that on film that was
really interesting so doesn't any I mean
and then he returns to DC like they were
fun to pass the video order this visitor
back in the DC you the returns that he
returns to non-recursive DC returns to
New York he meets
you meet some of Aaron Davis or and they
have the conversation about vocals I'm
not a womanizer
I'm coming for the Christian Bale this
mail I really were like or Glover wrote
some of it even if he does not writing
trend out like this seems like his right
like it was like I heard you earlier man
you don't sound like and now he says
later you got to get better at this but
there might be another joke you know
Andy Joe he's like make even it might be
making some joke to the DC Universe and
you know like a Batman suit his voice so
much and then Spiderman has that because
I love that Aaron Davis notices this
right oh just telling I'm not scared I'd
be right but also to Iron Man he can
change it and it's like a change the
voice like in the first Iron Man when
through the the terrorists he said he's
all yours and it didn't sound like
Robert day we had that it had that voice
in it somebody has it's an Iron Man suit
it's got that touch on yeah and that was
a really cool thing for the easter-egg
knowledge you have of it I really like
the way that plays out where the reason
why Aaron Davis decides to give
information to him because even the
scene Pryor established that Aaron Diaz
is like I'm not into this crazy like
technology terrorists blowing up stuff
crap even that small character gets
something of an arm yeah and make sense
why he's why he would give information
to spider-man but why spider-man leaves
in there is like desert that you're
Jerome user I create a human and he
harpin to the line or you know you said
he harpin to the line tor is said like
you saved me from being shot by them and
like you said if you're going to shoot
anyone to me so like it showed him like
oh this guy is willing to help out even
a bad guy so or a guy who doesn't have
to die yeah so I mean like you had
someone who found respect for him and -
I love seeing the enthusiasm and
excitement from Peter when he he's like
oh my god and he's like dude I got to
tell you so I gotta tell you
just like that's why he's a teenager
like that like he's got a lot of girl in
him and things to figure out and also I
like my Aaron Davis's line Donald over
slime where he says you got to get
better at this like yeah he's like
there's a lot of things he's gotta get
better because he's not the spider-man
we know yeah he's getting there so ok
people keep recognizing he's got grit
and also letting him know you gotta work
on this and I do like throughout the
most of the film I mean there are some
moments where we see someone go buddy
do a flip yeah kind of fine go like we
see a couple does but for the most part
this is the first time really where I've
seen a soul aspiring film when he's
gonna buy crowds of people and uh and
whatever there's a vendors around
destruction ever a we don't even talk we
have notes to talk about that we didn't
even mention how that montage money is
helping out people how people don't even
really appreciate what he's doing yet
even injured yeah half the time is kind
of mistaken like there's that whole
thing with the guys car
hey I accuse two making mistakes my
cards are dumbass
everyone game at a Stan Lee cameo and
really quick just mentioning about Stan
Lee I just want to say that it's very
sad what happened with his wife don't we
pass and also she was also if you watch
the 90s animated cartoon she's the voice
of Madame Webb who is the mentor dispute
or Parker in that dream I manage the
world so that that's Joan Lee's voice
and I love Madame Wong's one of my
all-time favorite characters in the
spider-man mythos so I was very sad to
hear below and again there's no hey it
happened on this day that's okay but the
fact that it happened to Dave Snider
making amount of just like really made
it extra sat on absolutely absolutely
well you know what it's a filmer be
proud of for sure the Lee family should
be proud of
so yes prayers go out to her the Easter
egg you there's a few there much of you
this one first and then we'll go ice 800
yeah right good one um so Aaron Davis
mentioned and one of the the interaction
in the interrogation mode or somewhere
in there he says that there's about a
demon in a psycho and a demon costume
that's kind of a reference to daredevil
who even though they don't really make
too many references it is in the same
universe also Aaron Davis if you know
anything about this character he is one
of the versions in the more and the
Ultimate Marvel Universe he's the
Prowler the version we saw in the 90s
version was Hobie Brown but this one
Aaron Davis is actually you hear him
talk about a nephew in the film that's
Miles Morales they are clearly planting
the seed from Miles Morales I'd say in
three four or five films to take over
when Peter Parker eventually dies or
maybe they'll go a different route say
he doesn't want to be spider-man anymore
yeah I'm going to do it Eddie Murphy
style where Donald Glover plays both his
uncle and miles and there's you doing a
green screen is done regret yeah but I
do like how they're kind of playing the
seats for Miles Morales right there is
the nephew mentioned we'll talk about
the end credits when they make another
Mouse moralising also too we see that
when Peters getting the facial
recognition recognition to find out it's
Aaron Davis it says on the thing aliases
the Prowler it also says aliases Brian
Pacelli this is a reference to the
author and artist of the Prowler which
was Brian Michael Bendis and also Sarah
Pacelli
so it's up that was really a nice homage
in the you know to them and they're the
ones who came up with the character of
Miles Morales and other characters in
the Marvel the Ultimate Marvel Universe
so that was really cool I noticed all
that I know you did Andrew just stole my
point sorry about that man hey this is
Halloween you want to get an Hollywood
you steal other people's idea that's
true that was pure works every time
and then now you know the famous scene
that I ever that was really promoted all
over the trailer the trailer kind of
ruins a lot four of you remember the
treasure the ferry scene that would
generate the tension it did break the
tension still cool absolutely cool watch
it's really well done but it does and
they're like the degenerates especially
when you know exactly how it's going to
play out it's kinda like their ego the
charms of that scene at least for me
came in just the extra thing the extra
detail there's four things you get to
see spider-man do and then the features
of the student gets to use like those
yeah make it nice and then they have
this in the sequence we'll go with this
one about Peter lying to Tony you don't
oh yeah and really quick I just want to
say just saying what you said about the
the trailer like it kind of happened
back a little also to Wonder Woman being
revealed in the Batman V Superman where
she saves Batman from doomsday it's like
great moment you defuse the tension by
showing is that so and I wish they would
just hold back on some of the moments
that they've shown in the trailers
because again the whole movie is not
ruined by the trailers but there are
some big plot points like I will
that moment I found very much ruined
because I'm like well I know exactly how
this is going to end with a fairy that's
in half and Peter's not gonna know what
to do I are masking the show up save the
day I'm gonna take the suit away it was
like man this was so much of the movie
it was his route for me from that trip
yeah
but beyond that it's still good and
there's details there and a couple of
details look you're lying about so when
Peter is talking on the ferry to Iron
Man or to Tony Stark and he says he's
making up a bunch of Lies like I'm at
band camp is like that doesn't sound
like my him I thought you quit six weeks
ago a happy that's what happy told me I
kind of reminds me a lot of what Tony
Stark didn't Ironman one where you
flying to Rhodey
and uh Terrence Howard's Rhodey by the
way at NIDA Don Cheadle but he's kind of
lined him saying I'm I am I'm jogging
out in the woods I'm driving through
town yeah it's just he's making like
these kind of picking up some Tony Stark
traits or he's like he easily kind of
lying and making up stuff so I like that
kind of references back a little bit to
Tony Stark so maybe have them more
apparent to why Tony would be like a
father figure
I definitely an OS Tony starting to
sound like his own father cuz Peter
reminds him of him yeah me and Tony
wants him to be better than him yeah so
and also too we get our first glimpse
ever and on the live-action version of
spider-man we get to see Mac Gargan aka
the scorpion and also he's got a
scorpion tattoo on his neck so really
cool to see him we'll talk about what
happens with him in the mid Christian
Way little later on that dude from
Breaking Bad better call Saul is going
to coast boys and we have I don't know
here FBI shows up on the ferry I think
John you said that you'd like the touch
for specific person yeah I appreciated
that because that to me reminded me of
civil war it because the whole the thing
that made the ferry scene still work a
bit for me was actually that was like
the FBI was actually preparing to crack
down on the vultures operation and bust
this up and we've seen this situation in
you know like a lot of cops thrillers
and stuff like that where it's like you
you bust in on situation because you
know like Peter knows what to do but he
doesn't know the whole context and that
reminded me of civil war the whole thing
where iron men is trying to work with
the the systems that are in place you
know agree on that we don't just use our
all-powerful machinery to do whatever we
want we have to work with the system and
I
that was a good call back to that in a
way that wasn't intrusive and that
showed Peter like you can't just rush
into these things because we might have
something in place yeah someone may have
listened to you absolutely and the scene
when iron man does take the suit away
from Peter Parker yeah we talked about
it or not sort of how it looks kind of
weird with the green screen but so I
said we'd rather go into detail about it
here but the scene itself even though
the point of that scene was kind of
ruined in the trailer it's still very
introspective when you're watching the
movie because yeah it's like the point
that scenes room from the trailer but
it's affected when you're watching it I
thought you made a pretty good point
well I just I like it like you guys have
said earlier I loved seeing Tony Stark
in a mentor role it's cool to see him a
different you know version of himself in
this because he's not we're not used to
seeing Tony in that perspective in this
film so I thought that was great because
he like he said he sees a lot of of
Peter Parker and him and he wants him to
be better than it yeah and you know if
going behind his back and doing these
things I love seeing the concern on
Robert guy's face like like I said it
feels like a younger version himself and
I love the line many points out time he
says if anybody had died that's on you
and if you died that's on me like it
just is a great line of how much he
cares about this kid like again doesn't
want anything bad to happen about he's
got enough cut age of Ultron was all
Tony Stark's starts well because of what
happened with Scarlet Witch where she
gave him a nightmare version which I'm
assuming as a foreshadowing for what
happens in infinity war but that being
said fear has controlled a lot of Robert
Downey's Tony Stark's decisions and he
doesn't want to have to worry about this
kid he wants you to be better so he
doesn't have to worry about him so I
thought it was a good moment not only
for for Tom Hong like because it's it's
the low point for him you know where
he's he's in his most vulnerable stage
he's in the darkest deepest place for
this character and I liked it from Tony
Stark's perspective because you
understand why he's taken the suit away
he doesn't want anything bad to happen
in the scale so I thought was a great
moment even if it was ruined a little
from the trailers and that's like one of
a couple of those father figure moments
where those guys tell them well you
don't know how all of this works you
know because there's one later with
Michael Keaton - yeah I lost moment he
loses the suit because all of it does
the whole point
doing all this was because he want to be
an Avenger now he's being told he cannot
even have that opportunity it's perfect
it won't happen he's not an intern
anymore not an intern and yet to the
dark night of the soul Laureus I just I
just love that look on his face with
that me where he's like laughing she's
like where have you been I've been
wearing like what the internship and
like you like you see my favorite anyone
that is my favorite scene that may
because a lot of the movie you know and
especially after Civil War it's like
yeah we get a young hot fun anime and it
and here we get that scene worth like
she's really freaking yeah yeah she's
been in a panic and worry and I like
that a lot of like I'm not trying to
ruin your life
you know like that really understanding
and because the attorney says online to
him if you're nothing without the suit
then you shouldn't have it and his whole
goal with having a suit and doing all
this was also to become a part of the
Avengers but in this dark no soul
journey he starts to get his personal
life back on track with the nice little
touches of he's getting himself like
taking school seriously again he build
the Death Star with Ned and then he
asked Liz to homecoming it kind of I'm
so sorry I'll let you go but it just
really just everything he does described
which is correct it kinda reminds me a
little of spider-man to with told me why
we're after at riding he's everything
he's not he's not spider-man anymore
he's given up the suit and obviously you
know being in love with Mary Jane
holding it in is what is causing those
powers but just his getting his life
back on track he's able to go to school
now he's able to answer dr. Curt Connors
as questions and that's her so it kind
of like yeah but just everything he
described like that really reminded me a
little of badge it's him getting back on
track again from a personal perspective
with not having to worry about the
responsibility of being spider-man cos
he amenity he's 15 years old right right
when there's such a push-pull with his
life with his personal life as Peter
Parker we're like every time an
opportunity arises you really want him
to take them and yeah never gets to and
so you know having having a sequence
like that where he does just get back to
life you know I thought they played that
off in a really nice way in this movie
you know yeah yeah absolutely and you
know I get I do like that list agrees to
go to the dance them and then we know
you talking anymore about the rest of
the song for something really
interesting happy and nothing else is
driving the real movie entering the
total pile is one of the biggest
personal item talking about this okay
when we get to the finale I mean I like
I like the touches of especially you
were talking about earlier with a may
helping him learn how to do a Windsor
knot with his tie Susan Rose little
interactions were really really nice a
single mom action and I was thinking
like okay here's what's going to happen
cuz especially because the trailers have
this scene where they show he's going to
the hall taking off his homecoming suit
I'm like okay he's gonna go to
homecoming with lettuce it's going to be
going well and they even have a scene in
d'etre ler where Liz goes in to kiss Tom
Holland which is not a Jane you notice
about that herbal shelter there's
actually quite a good amount to I'm not
related and every other day I want to
get that ended the first trick that was
there's a whole video on all the shops
that were knotted in and so I thought
your extended edition so I felt like
losers going to kiss him and then
something was gonna happen he was gonna
have to bail on homecoming played out
totally different with a really great
plot twist that I thoroughly enjoyed and
made the whole thing much more
suspenseful but he's nervous as hell but
is he's optimistic and hopeful that you
can have a great time with Liz at
overcoming this door opens and it's I
didn't a crowds reaction to or their
ever look good yeah yeah it's Adrian
Toomes and first you're like what was
happening and it didn't go to break yeah
you gonna torture that I have yeah yeah
you're wondering what's going on if I
always dad all-time and the way that
whole interaction was going down that's
great because you can see why Michael
Keaton would perceived Tom Halden is
just going through a nervous boy he
ain't the parent this is homecoming and
all all the anxiety of that and I like
how he's having fun with it because my
competing is not he's not playing up the
sinister stuff but he still seems a
little sinister you're playing with a
knife your little pale a little bit I
like my name when she comes in the room
with a corsage and Peter's like just
doesn't
here's it's like there's just so much on
his mind he can't be in the moment with
Liz he's really natural in that whole
know what he really does look like a
dude has been completely I don't
off-guard but that in a car when they're
in the car driving and happen or
whatever one of the best things of the
movie there's so much tension and add
scene fulfills oh and I love how
cleverly you know Adrienne James fake is
figuring it out it's loading it together
and in the world of the MCU it's not
implausible to think that this kid could
be a hero with all the crazy
supernatural stuff he's a witness to of
court it is like it's not going to
realize as a kid you know so as I play
on I even like of even a little detail
touch of Liz remembers this voice - yeah
yeah oh yeah that's right that's a good
touch I like that because you always
wonder when you watch a movie how does
nobody is recognizes boy they had when
you won buddy and in this world we're
like superheroes and people with
advanced abilities are more common you
would and would stand out if you heard
something you sounded like a kid yeah I
was more talking like in spider-man
wimba Sam Raimi's when like he taught me
just to talk to Mary Jane Watson my gang
a cheeseburger that saves her two
minutes later and misfire Manson like
literally still sounds like tell me
where how can you tell oh yeah and that
like wire doesn't has kind of a distinct
voice yeah slowly away but with that
would that see know anything as he's
figuring it out I mean there's a little
possible Easter Egg too when he said it
as the green light I don't know if it's
an easter egg but I just I really
noticed some more the second time when
Keith's finally discovered Adrian Toomes
it's finally discovered that Peter is of
course spider-man first of all he's got
that that look on his face I'm like I
just solved the big mystery and then the
light turns green and the green is
really like stuck on his face and of
course leads us to say them dead green
light go I just thought it was
interesting how the green was really
shining on his face because you know
green is such a big color for this
character you know from the green
jagwire to the green color of the
vulture suit so I don't I just felt like
it was kind of a little bit of a
whatever symbolism kind of
of the character so I thought that was a
little cool yeah and he gives that
threat to Peter in the car which is
scary
let me give Peters a dead dog yeah that
was so bro you thought he was going to
do the Beetlejuice voice didn't
intimidate him but for the Batman is you
know kind of thing but that was that was
a really great moment and you are
wondering what Peters going to do you
know like Peters given up being
spider-man he doesn't even have a suit
anymore so he can't do all these things
and that moment where he just find Liz
and tells her he's sorry and he has to
go that was so well done and you that's
like I felt both feelings of the hero
sacrifice so I felt proud for him and I
don't really bother him at the same time
you know because that is the Sakura this
isn't about that moment isn't about
taking down the vulture to prove to Tony
that he can be an Avenger exposed it's
about doing the right standards and it
always takes the sacrifice yeah from
posess to Peter Parker is he does the
right he had it just has to do the right
thing yeah I'm just adding more to what
you said about that whole cart one of my
favorite scenes ever in the film and the
tension in that scene to build up I love
it I also do love their interaction with
just them in the car only and he's
talking about you did save my daughter
and I appreciate that like he's got a
coat a better reading for right oh yeah
because like my when I saw my dad before
the conversation started I was like why
is he killing him and then we are like
he's like okay that may ask that's like
so this character is nice of that kind
of bill yeah he's not a villain like
he's got you know a principal and a code
to him and there's a reason why he's
doing doing everything is for in his
family he's trying to provide a good
life for his family and like we said in
the beginning kind of got victimized by
the whole Tony taking damage control
over and not even giving him a head work
that when you invested so much so and
all about a family room Michael Keaton's
vulture is a great example of the
distinction between a villain and and
antagonist yeah be antagonist but he's
not just a villain right now no I agree
it's very three-dimensional on the
second second Peter leaves homecoming
first off like a little touch of when he
lifts up the Locker and the suits -
what's it all this dude is yeah magic
Locker block come from he's also I love
how he hosted that - always look around
to make sure no one's there
time of course endo in there but that's
yeah and the second he leaves shocker
shocker number two he shows you just hit
her Mitchell starts and it's neat
because yeah it's like it is more
dangerous now that he doesn't have his
super spider-man suit you know he just
has his clothes this disguise and that
fight was good and I really do
appreciate them dead gotta have that
moment he got his guy in the chair yeah
hey shoot Simeon and he comes and it
he's like good shot very shy and I agree
with you that a great moment I'm glad it
was in the film but just in terms of
like weeps of logic it didn't make a ton
of sense that voltar has literally just
figured out that Peter was spider-man on
the way to that homecoming in so I'm
guessing it's like about five to ten
minutes from when he figured out to when
they get to the dance and Peter did it's
not like they were at the dance for 20
30 40 minutes and Peter bolted the
second he got there and then Herman
Schultz is just waiting for him and I
know New York is a very small town it's
not very big or anything and he could
probably get there in less than two
minutes I get it's a movie but I just
felt like how is he there so but whoa
that was quick he I mean again it's a
great scenes a good moment for Ned just
leaps of logic I just didn't understand
how he was there so fast well he might
have he might oh I kind of think that
yeah with this character agent Jim she
kind of always has his main guys near
him and so he may be headed out of town
on a job well yeah they're probably late
I have to go drop my daughter off you
got to be near me all those families
think yes I could sue okay yeah I'm just
defending the movie it has no flaws its
own trying to tell you man eight years
later Tuesday hate yourself yeah years
later um so yeah and then I didn't have
a moment where uh Peter does is he Jack
the car first or just the jaws on the
car okay they jettison said before he
meets up with Adrian Toomes
he just yeah uh now D from flat yeah the
Audi commercial uh that's really what it
wasn't even that I was like I it took me
a second of leeway does not address yeah
I got no idea how we feel like out he
and Acura the biggest cars for me at
Marvel Cinematic Universe well what I
liked about that scene was you know at
any moment Peter could knock out flash
dollars at any
one and and spider-man one and in the
amazing spider-man part one they have
seen where Peter does get his revenge
where he indulged yeah he does indulge
in like fighting back at this guy
whether it's humiliating him or
physically hurting him and here it's
it's not perceived as that it's not
perceived as him getting his revenge now
he doesn't even get this glorious moment
about it but he does get to have his
little jab at him he doesn't ruin
flashing he does Ruta fly the day
embarrasses him in front of his girl and
ruining him with his reputation with his
dad and ourselves so he does get to have
a humiliating moment there till I was
really fun
I'm sure flash hasn't out cuz you know
spider-man took them yes Elsa to his den
is pretty rich so fixing up that car's
not going to be there a little bit I
agree was a good revenge without it
feeling like an actual revenge moment
for our beer towards flash' I like to do
it and I even like the scene when Peter
shows up and confronts Adrian Toomes and
Adrienne is giving his feel about you
know like the big people on top they
don't care about us and then the way
they show moments of that and the
trailer I thought like it made me think
bolts are just going to be this villain
who's chewing up the scenery the two
dimensional builders maybe here's what's
wrong with the society but it's strange
because in that moment even though he
sells it off as just it's a distraction
moment he's also giving an explanation
to why he does it and what are you
saying I'm like yeah you know I still
get it's an old movie later and I'm
still like I get where you're coming
from honestly I don't attend you're a
terrible guy I understand your Vendetta
and yeah and he kind of made mention to
to computed like where do you think
start got that building from by selling
drugs to a you know a legal view or
legal drugs to a terrorist or something
that kind was a little bit of a
reference to August Obadiah Stane from
Iron Man 1 played by Jeff Bridges that's
exactly what he did when he worked for
this reason that's a big way of how they
made money and that yeah and that's
where Tony you know I had to turn the
page like we cannot sell the kind of
weapon so he did have a point Michael
Keaton except he wasn't he was wrongly
and referring to Tony Stark that way was
more of a
but that was cool a little bit as saying
a you know called by there and I like
that even even Tony Stark is complicit
in that and that's part of learning less
than that movie yeah
did you also notice too when you've uh
when after spider-man wets his arm and
then he's like no I'm just wait I was
just distracting or something like that
and then the whole Diana hit you yeah
but but the wings come in and Peter or
Pitts firemen backflips out of the way
it really reminded me a lot of the first
Raimi spider-man when Green Goblin dies
he's got speed spider-man and then the
got the the glider comes in and then
Peter has to jump out away and it's just
impaled the Goblin it really happened
back to remind me how Harry yeah it
visually reminded me of that
so yeah and they also have the moment
that I really like learn ed gets to
literally become the guy in the air that
[ __ ] he gets to become the new a headset
who's helping Peter figure out locations
of where we go or future yeah he's
Oracle with Felicity he dies everyone
and I like no he proclaims it probably
kinda chair guy in the chair and the
funniest joke out of the hole oh I know
where you go he definitely had when
because what do you doing guys I was
thinking who would say this yeah but I
wasn't expecting them to go there and it
was his delivery that made it so funny
when the teacher walks in because
there's a dance going on what are you
doing here I was looking yes it's like
this that everything is kind of an
obvious joke but at the same time you're
like well if you're being practical we
have it without like you're just copping
decided out because like if you try to
make up an outlandish the excuse is only
going to cause them to come over and
check your [ __ ] out so have the scene
that I think stood out for a lot of
people as for a movie that's filled with
a ton of laughs there is one very strong
emotional scene that is when the roof
top collapses onto Peter and he can't
get up and he's feeling weak he's
screaming for out to nobody he's calling
out the nobody yeah he hasn't he has no
one at that moment fleetly hopeless and
I heard because it did bother me for a
second when he sees his reflection and
then they do the whole voiceover the
callbacks narration of
Tony Stark when I heard that they did
that because of like it's a specific
line from the comic book or something I
used to leave you're ready I don't have
everybody believe you're right that the
whole moment of me lifting up the oh
yeah I was looking at the any commercial
yeah it's from the comic says you're
right but that that scene when he is
struggling to get up and he's finding
the motivation himself this is all going
to the whole point of what Tony Stark
wanted him to do to be like if you're
nothing without the student you don't
deserve it this is him becoming that
thing that Tony wants him to be because
he's not even just saying come on Peter
come on spider-man come on I like I
would call himself spider-man there
Jonah he's more than this and he finds
the strength so it's also about him
wanting to find his strength which I
really like I can't really think of a
scene and any of the other spider-man
films where I've seen the character like
in such a peril moment where I'm like I
really feel you so powerless and could
just really die it right now in this one
Mary Jane is breaking up with him in the
park oh good call dude absolutely i
remembers my theater stars laughing
during that moment too but no like just
hearing the agony and Tom Hardy's voices
a feeling the feeling of are Tom Hardy
Ben oh hey Tom Tom Holland I'm mark a by
the way little fun thing Tom Hardy
played vane right Bane gets injected
with venom now Tom Hardy is playing
venom Oh
inqilab we threw that in there so uh um
but I'm getting back to what I was
saying I loved seeing Tom Hollands voice
of of desperation a feeling of like
powerlessness feeling of powerlessness
they're like oh wait please buddy I'm
like I just I really felt in the moment
I felt so claustrophobic and the moment
was I'm like like spider get out of
there do like okay I kind of also like
felt a little bit like that movie with
Ryan Reynolds bury that claustrophobic
feeling where the character is just in
peril and stuff yeah like that really
really affected me and I wasn't
expecting that from this movie - yeah
that that was one of the most surprising
and impactful moments I think it was a
great great scene and I thought it was a
good balancing tone from all the humor
we've gotten through episode like it
balances out that tone promise huh it
doesn't really fit you now yeah we get
to the plane sequence you know good
things further shows you that that
happens
where
but any learns fun stuff on the job in
the plane that happy is loading for Tony
he's transporting a lot of stuff this is
a final to the New Avengers headquarters
on that plane there's a couple of things
that you notice yeah one of the main
things I notice obviously we see one of
the Iron Man masks and we see some
Chitauri weapon from the Bell weapons
from the valley New York but a big one
that stood out to me in the background
when with Michael Keaton's Adrian Toomes
you see the mark 42 Iron Man 2 which was
the Iron Man main Iron Man suit an Iron
Man 3 and of course that too was
destroyed when it got onto aldrich
killian and he self-destructed it but
obviously of course he's rebuilt that
suit and put it in here so I thought
that was a nice little homage set up to
Iron Man 3 yeah and the plain sequence
was cool that was one of the is a really
good action sequence for sure I mean not
a whole lot there to really touch on
it's like for me when they're useful to
review some about bring down the details
the action sequences or talking about
cool these things are it's more the
emotional states and the consequences of
what's going on as they set up the
weapon that he has to do with the couple
a to the altitude
Oh oh yeah it's that altitude sealant
thing yeah yeah well yeah when the plane
goes down and then it crashes you don't
get like a huge fight scene and like a
lot of these movies build up to between
vulture and Spider Man Spidey's like
getting his ass kicked for a lot of it
actually and slightly actually loses the
fight if you think about it he loses the
fight because then butch was about to
get away and but because of his own
mistake it explodes the Winky is look he
doesn't realize that he's picking up a
thing that's about to blow
but Peter then does have a Redemption
moment I added the Windows Explorer is
that the thing that explodes in there I
think it's way side the wings to the
wing trends that crashed through the
area and so that's where he sees the
zoomed in on the box of our career could
be right but I thought it was the wings
but anyway the point of he recognizes
he's in danger and he really tries to
warn ya
to save him he knows what it's like to
be fatherless he doesn't want that for
Liz and he cares about her isn't that he
does had what he doesn't want that
having cares for Liz and the computer
doesn't want to see anybody a tiny baby
their expositional dialogue in that
scene where he's like think about Liz
the girl I'm in love with like I can't
believe you said that yeah you do your
daughter your daughter the black woman
I'm in love with are you her dad she
doesn't look half white why does she
have a different last name you're an
intruder
like this is a big opportunity like they
just said all this exposition with Idol
yeah but I want to say this scene where
they're fighting on the airplane and
he's not in that Iron Man Spider of the
the Spider suit and you don't feel he's
got that protection of the parachute and
other things like he's in the other hand
is he's in that old-school suit and it
had nothing without this and when he's
thirty thousand feet in the air like
again from that moment you mentioned on
the described in the Washington Monument
where he's like over the edge like the
me being you know so scared of heights
like just him being up there and that
zoom like I have so much danger in
tension in that in those moments and
voltar's obviously got the high ground
he's the one he's he's able to fly in
spiders stuck to it and Wayne and I was
glad that vulture did not die you know I
guess first off a lot of times in Marvel
villain get killed off that could
probably be better explored in future
installments it's not his favorite and
also you know like him dying and stuff
lately we've had that with other
spider-man models and prior spider-man
films would have been a lot of Green
Goblin reference II to me if that
happened in its own way but I'm glad
that spider-man did still get to save
his life and vulture respects that you
can see like without them saying
anything it won't not you can see that
that's probably adds on to the list of
the mid credit sequence as to why
Michael Keaton does not reveal that he
knows who Peter Parker and he also
mentions to so I'm sorry good oh no that
that just that really caught me up
because I found myself going
I really hope Peter can save him yeah
and and he does save him and I love the
the call back to him relieving a note of
the Bennett paper got the vulture that
respect you're talking about from Adrian
Toomes to pee
Parker like he even says when Peter
confronts him before the roof collapse
I'm like Peter you really got grit like
I did when I when you came up to the
house I was like what is it this button
how I see it
oh yeah like he there is a kind of a
Reggie's a little guy and you'd respect
some qualities that that Peter does have
you know so and then they have the same
where you know they're deciding whether
or not Peter should get kicked expelled
out of school and that's with another
Easter egg and you're taking away hey so
I pointed this out to you in the theater
when this was happening we see Kenneth
Choi who was also was in Suicide Squad
too by the way
guy gets around the comic book films he
actually plays Jim Morita in Captain
America the First Avenger one of the
Howling Commandos and in this film same
accurate evasion guy and the first event
let's not label people but yes that is
correct though but yeah and in this film
same actor he's playing principal Morita
so and also we see a picture in black
and white of of Jim Morita from the
First Avenger Captain America the First
Avenger film in his office so I'm
assuming that's his grandfather or
something like what he had the super
serum to could idea to saving the world
more being a bad guy he decided to my
people figured out maybe or you per
serum just went all to bring yeah it's
got really good a bit frozen in you I
believe that it could have been frozen
in time of day could have been frozen
that bedroom use a hose on the ship the
whole time I got a regular and then
Peter doesn't get the girl
poreless her whole art issues is
devastated by that poor lady and man
that that's another great thing about
like that there's no deus ex machina for
that is i thought that that scene went
out beautifully just lay up yeah hey
pete whatever's going on you hope you
figure it out and they leave that on a
bittersweet name yet and i like and you
know we haven't talked about happy that
much in a new spoiler review I like the
bathroom sequence
hahahahaha I thought was this was a
little weird that a grown man
high school boys back there right up an
awkwardness from the other kid yeah and
I like how happy is having a little r2
of like I owe you an apology I owe you
one
yeah yeah I owe you one and then no
beers like you're good the bathroom
knows like and then of course you know
the big scene Iron Man what about MJ
Michelle oh yeah yeah that big thing
Michelle says her name is MJ which has
some people in an uproar because of like
this isn't the Mary Jane Watson this is
totally different and indebted ah but
then you were saying something separate
well I mean her character's name is
Michelle Jones obviously they're against
the cloning Jessica Jones's sister yeah
hell did they're all connected guys um
but I know like your name is Michelle
Jones and this and obviously they're
making reference that she's this version
of Mg in this version of the character
spider-man but her name is not Mary Jane
Watson so it's I think you put a bed but
it's just a little confusing mercifully
but is it but it's a more like you know
how Joseph gordon-levitt says that Dark
Knight Rises is really interrupt them
and he's not really a Robin you know
what I mean I think it's because I kind
of like yeah we have an MJ but it's not
really the marriage I think it kind of
feels more like that good like yeah I'm
not calling her Mary Jane Watson
I love the die in this film like if they
want to make her Mary Jane Watson fine I
guess but Cobra Mary Jane Watson Betsy
is about the Robin thing there was
something about that or it's like the
tone was different I look ok I get it
like this is your guy on the force who
you kind of you you trust in and so like
in that sense I was like ok it's not
exactly in line with the comics but ever
I don't I didn't mind that as much as
this just kind of confused me yeah
because there's only so much I think
that there's only so much you can change
something before it's just not that
thing anymore so I was confused as to
what they're behind and it has nothing
to do with her race first off we wanna
make that clear ultimately it doesn't
behave like Mary yeah and we don't have
the history the metagame appear to be
developing a puppet well yeah it's like
that is that is not the romantic
chemistry there's always a lot of things
it just seems so different from what MJ
is supposed to be tat Peter Parker that
and she
a crush on him yet but it changes so
drastically that it's like it just
doesn't seem like MJ and I'm all for
something different to entertaining
something different but I thought the
way that they revealed that if you only
made it confusing to me because I was
like oh this is clearly you want this to
be a moment I don't get yeah yeah quite
past that though we get to the I we get
to the scene where Tony swear he goes to
the avengers headquarters is there
anything they Peter in the beginning
wanted was to become a part of the
Avengers be inducted in his treatment
and Tony Stark is like hey I was all
wrong about it all the dialogues
different than it wasn't the trailer and
that's good in the trailer people
because I didn't notice whatever
dialogue I think did this it throw us
all not the end yet they just wanted
more Tony Stark watching the trailers
and they make it seem like he's in it
more I think so when they have them to
have that scene John our assignment on
the car ride home you didn't see it
coming him rejecting the suitor because
you weren't even thinking about it you
weren't thinking ahead oh yeah I was
just pulled into the point that I wasn't
sure about what Apple eating yeah for me
I was like I I felt like okay this is
the arc he's going to be going through
he's going to deny the suit but it's
still a very effective moment and it
brings it all back to what the main
theme and point of this spider-man is of
him being the friendly neighborhood
spider-man I love that he didn't say
yeah I want to be a part of the Avengers
still he was saying I just want to be
you know I gotta look out for the little
guy makes it more interesting makes it
more interesting make some more person
will make some more Spidey because it
doesn't just make it we got some other
men in the MCU let's Avengers him up you
know I can respect a movie or a show or
any story that doesn't give you what you
want but it gives you something that's
true or that you need it gives them the
art
and it gives them to character art and
it also turns them into what what uh
what Iron Man was at wanted Peter to be
that's something more than that and even
like the thing about it Sam is reporters
outside and Shane places it s is s yep
Testament and Easter eggs on drag every
yeah and really quick to just like so I
think what harpin Peters and making a
big part of that decision when he wasn't
with the iron spider-man sued me more
he was like you like he was getting his
life back on track in an order and again
I think he just wants to keep it simple
he just wants to keep his feet on the
ground something he wants leave Ned
behind for sure I think the guy knew
Peter Parker is going to be gay
and I'm excited for that I can see it I
can see it too
hey man I would love gay Peter for I
mean I feel like when we get gay couples
it's like they're both been imagine i
thi madly electric imagine if here and
imagine centreford ruins dating Miles
Morales oh that would be cool hmm two
spider-men let's go to the easter eggs
now in their IRA I am looking inside I
did appreciate just as a sidebar just
how diverse the movie is without again
being screaming about it yeah you know
and one other thing I wanted to work on
the Easter eggs I also like tough Tony
Stark was kind of taking a little crimp
like so when I was being a hard-ass and
you got inspired that got you back did
it like you like this I like no
self-awareness of the man yeah yeah but
but I did like seeing like how again we
see that moment that the impact of how
much Tony really cares about this kid
seeing him like you said being better
than him making the right decision like
that's the faith he saw in him from the
beginning annecy and like it's watching
like a father watches son turn into a
magnet it's a great moment it plays off
it's played up beautifully in the film
between Tom Holland and Robert Downey
jr. exactly there's so much to that art
that makes it so pivotal for who's
spider-man is and it was beautifully
done both go to the Easter Egg solo if
you notice the shirt that Peter Parker's
wearing when he's going to get the
ultimate spider-man suit it says I lost
an electron you might have said what it
said on the back ed or are you positive
yeah yeah so that's the shirt that
Pepper Potts wears in Iron Man 3 when
she's viciously woke up when Tony's
having a nightmare from the battle in
your sequence oh that's the same shirt
so cool those hormones obviously the
suit that Tony is trying to present that
the the iron spire suit from the comics
I got to believe even though he turned
it down in this one that suits badass by
the way he could go infinity it's going
to be an opinion or when he's fighting
Fay knows he's going to need some kind
of protection or food and that too it
looks like it's a sign of reproduction I
wish they would do that kind of with all
the suit like the Black Panther
with Captain America make the suit like
get given an Iron Man touch I said be
cool to see on all the characters
apparently pepper and Tony or worked
everything out we didn't need another
movie to have them happy yeah off screen
like we heard in Civil War that they
broke up they're back together in this
but they know a lot of stranger holier
but there's a couple of Easter eggs when
happy takes up the the engagement ring
two things to notice there one he says
I've had this in my pocket since 2008
that's the year jon favreau directed
Iron Man 1 which launched off the Marvel
Cinematic Universe also if you notice
when he pulls the ring out you see a
shot of Pepper Potts clearly in frame
with the ring in happy Hogan's hand they
actually get married in the comics so I
felt that was a little bit of a nod to
them getting married in the comics even
though I don't know if that's going to
happen you know what our chance because
it looks like Tony and pepper possibly
going to get married but of course they
could always break up off screen before
Avengers infinity war so we don't have
any or not get married Oscar and we
don't know they're gonna break up during
yeah
then you know a spoiler reviews don't
stop with Marvel after the movies done
no no no you got credit stuff to talk
about
you admitted we left the theater right
when the cruzado riot and nobody was
shouting at us and everyone just walked
down or just walk down make you wonder
woman you made people think never to
kiss him after a post-credits scene so
the credit sequence you notice something
yes so if you notice spider-man in by
the way there's kind of like an MTV
sequence on the whole the lion sequence
I loved all that but if you looked at
spider-man set of face on some of the
shots like the colors were changing in
its phase to the Miles Morales color so
again they're really harpin and throwing
that a little bit to us like we're
planting that seed of Miles Morales it's
coming at some point maybe not in some
two or three but at some point it will
come especially that Easter Egg we got
with Aaron Davis in his nephews and
isn't Donald Glover developing an
animated Miles Morales di dementia for
FXX yeah I can't wait - that sounds
awesome so yeah nobody know yeah there
was a dialogue we got from all this [ __ ]
you know you don't know how that
happened you could I gotta you guys got
a new song
something and in the mid-credits scene
they have Adrian does not reveal to
scorpion that he knows who Spidey is why
why Andrew well I think you mentioned
that they've been mentioned earlier yeah
Dave his life what do you think that
means for the future scorpions going to
be the well there's letting up they're
setting up the sinister six for sure and
also to what I noticed on that scene
with it looked like appeared that the
prism that they were in was the wrath
the prison from Captain America Civil
War that's in the middle of the Atlantic
Ocean last time we of course all that
was in that film where we saw Captain
America breaking out the Avengers at the
end of that film that weren't prison
they're so cool a cool touch but also it
lets you know like the threat level that
they thought about the Avengers when
they're putting criminals of that nature
into these kinds of prison subs sure yes
Greg and Andrew but I think the
important thing to take away from the
credits is at the very end because you
know what after the credits there's a
great bit about patience Darin Captain
America
we get our own TSA that was from really
entrust it was that's one of the best
self-aware Marvel Nova I got seen a long
time it's just cap against a white
background talking to us about how we
waited around her husband Ivan okay Ron
I think that was a foreshadowing for
Avengers infinity where they were
setting up a scene and getting us ready
for that that's really what I think
they're setting up that infinity war
orientation for it and it's not going to
be worth anyone's time yeah it's going
to be a waste of money and you know what
I thought was kind of interesting in
Captain America Civil War the the
post-credit scene is a Peter Parker with
a many as you see him doing the
spider-man flash light up and then anime
is kind of questioning him about where
you got the market is like from this guy
Steve from Brooklyn but I liked how in
this film now in spider-man so now
Captain America gets the post-credits
scene so I thought that was pretty cool
too
I like when Captain America makes cameos
in other Marvel films or the dark world
that may have been like a woman oh
you're going to you had to a meeting
like I make they make use of him being a
comedic element and I appreciate that
because it really perceived Captain
Americans being a funny dude you know
Chris Evans has played so many funny
characters well because his movies are
especially the second two are very
intense and very real leader of The
Avengers knees are very much more
serious and straightforward so it's nice
that we don't it is awkward nasai can be
funny to words like I understood that
reference yeah moments like that and
like you can relate to that because he's
a man at a time yeah but he doesn't
really crack too many jokes he's not
really to perceive it like being one of
the funny daggers so it's cool that he
makes these cameos they make they happen
to do something that's intentionally
really quick every time they cut to one
of his PSAs because the three you see in
this movie so you got detention yeah
those are all really funny Misha get in
shape I know the feeling of a body
changing yeah to your gym teacher on the
other side it was great and then now I
mean there was one more additional user
that I've made a note of that I thought
maybe you want to point out do you want
me to plant you don't want to point it
out if you do it any owns Marvel and
Star that's the reason well very much
that is the right yeah I'm really just
really going more into it obviously we
see the Death Star the Lego Death Star
and you've also got the Lego Emperor
Palpatine
we also I believe we see an x-wing
inside of Peters room a toy version of
the x-wing also if you remember in
Captain America Civil War for the idea
that he got for taking down giant man
see what I did there
he got that from Empire Strikes Back
where the snowspeeder with wedge and
Jensen piloting it that's what they did
so clearly he's a die-hard Star Wars fan
which something we can all relate to for
the most part it had and also - I like
that it really shows that the Kevin
Feige of course but the creators of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe they're big
Star Wars fences if you watch the phase
2 films you know Thor the dark world
Iron Man 3 guardians of the galaxy
Captain America Winter Soldier and
Avengers age of Ultron in each of those
movies someone like Luke Skywalker loses
a hand so there's a lot of in Phase two
where Star Wars Easter eggs and I like
other again harpooning it from Captain
America Civil War with the snow speeder
reference and of course this they're big
diehard fans of building things Star
Wars was so I love that and again it
just it's more relatable for people like
us who are die hard Star Wars sounds
like I totally relate since pyromania I
love to let's start
so it's cooler no he's a nurse he's and
he's a fan too like us like it feels
like even though we don't have powers
like we are spider-man we're that care
iron what's up yeah this film is great
fantastic it's amazing we're wrapping
this video up finally you got around
this one I appreciate what this review
is Greg Jon and Andrews spoiler review
that was Greg Jon and Andrews theories
and predictions and that was Andrews
Easter Egg notices with Greg and John
with dragon John's help of knowing when
to insert them properly while discussing
them good job guys good job
research to reviewing Andrew you are the
head of this review I really appreciate
you being here you have no idea I
pleasure it's his birthday in a couple
days happy birthday Andrew thank you I
know it's your birthday as a birthday
present I thought hey why don't I give
you some attention on this channel
that's the most I'll offer you not
actual money through a run physical
present I'm going to I you another shirt
just a little promotion to go check him
out on the movie source channel movie
source channel on YouTube that he does
with his cousin Jason go check him out
on there they got a lot of great videos
obviously this guy knows what he's
talking about when it comes the cinema
he's a cinephile just and love him I
want him on the Schmo down if you would
destroy it your game if you guys made it
to the end of this long ass discussion
three uh Karloff there's a lot you want
movie source anyone an egg or 7-eleven
that's the Twitter handle on the Schmo
doubt if he deserves to be on there for
sure hey man if we were a three-person
team you are triple sec through
yeah one day I'm just going to call them
sick but I can't make it Andrews gonna
fill in for me yeah well then I miss
every pack and then I miss every crest
question and they're good don't ever
suggest anyone again well guys thanks
for being here subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
leave a comment is there some Easter Egg
you notice or a theory you want to leave
down come on comment leave me get me an
interactive grip join the conversation
dad John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of Blum
house check out our patreon for
exclusive rewards awesome perks for
having a ton of fun over there and as
always when dimension one more time NGO
Gordon egg or 7-eleven on Twitter movie
source channel will be source he's the
man go watch spider-man homecoming
obviously it's worth it kid